on retrouve Josephine Staron directrice
des études et relations internationales
du sing tank sinopia le laboratoire des
gouvernances docteurs en philosophie
politique bonjour on décrit Vladimir
Poutine comme une personnalité
irrationnelle et paranoïaque c'est très
personnalité n'explique pas à eux seuls
une politique nationaliste qui regrette
la Grande Russie
non c'est quand même quelque chose qui
était ancré depuis quelques années ça
fait 20 ans que Vladimir Poutine
montre finalement aux Occidentaux sa
volonté d'étendre la sphère d'influence
de la Russie de redorer le blason de la
Grande Russie et finalement peut-être
d'avoir sa revanche sur un système
international qui depuis quelques années
là un peu banalisé la mis au banc on se
souvient qu'il a été retiré du G8 ce qui
est devenu ensuite un G7 qui l'a subi de
nombreuses sanctions économiques et
commerciales qui faisait suite bien
évidemment au transgression du droit
international on l'a vu en Géorgie on
l'a vu en Crimée on le voit maintenant
en Ukraine donc est-ce qu'il y a une
forme de paranoïa peut-être mais en tout
cas on ne peut pas être tout à fait
surpris de cette volonté de réaffirmer
la puissance de la Russie c'est quelque
chose qui est dans l'imaginaire
collectif et surtout dans celui de
Vladimir Poutine et au gouvernement
depuis qu'il est arrivé au pouvoir il
emploie les mêmes méthodes que celle du
KGB et celle de l'URSS qui n'hésitait
pas à envoyer l'armée rouge occuper la
Tchécoslovaquie en août 68 oui il faut
pas oublier que Vladimir Poutine est
issu lui-même du KGB donc c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît parfaitement ces
méthodes-là qui est probablement en
nostalgie aussi de cette époque de
l'époque de la Grande Russie et qui qui
aujourd'hui montre aux Occidentaux que
on passe de la parole aux actes qu'il
est capable de de réaliser les menaces
qu'il a qu'il a proféré depuis de
nombreuses années il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'on était dans un monde depuis
quelques temps ou
la dissuasion on pensait en tout cas que
ça pouvait suffire qu'on était dans un
monde où les sanctions et là et la
menace de sanction pouvait être
suffisamment forte pour empêcher
l'action en tout cas des actions
militaires et on se rend compte
aujourd'hui de manière brutale en Europe
que la guerre peut survenir à tout
moment et Vladimir Poutine et celui qui
nous fait prendre conscience
dramatiquement de cette nouvelle donne
les fondements est-ce que les fondrement
de l'URSS et l'humiliation ressentie par
le peuple russe à cette occasion sont
d'après vous des éléments déterminants
pour comprendre la situation actuelle
oui
après il faut peut-être distinguer le
peuple russe et Vladimir Poutine on n'a
pas suffisamment d'informations
aujourd'hui pour savoir si le peuple
russe dans sa majorité soutient le la
guerre en Ukraine aujourd'hui mais il
est certain que ça fait quand même
quelques années que l'OTAN essaye
d'étendre sa sphère d'influence vers
l'est et que Vladimir Poutine met en
garde les Occidentaux en disant si vous
continuez nous nous aussi nous nous
chercherons à nous étendre vers l'ouest
donc même s'il est évident que Vladimir
Poutine est respons capable de cette
situation et qu'il a pensé depuis de
nombreux mois voire de nombreuses années
cela fait c'est finalement une réponse à
la à l'extension aussi de l'OTAN il faut
se rappeler que la plupart des pays de
l'ex-Union soviétique sont rentrés dans
l'Union européenne et dans l'OTAN et que
donc la sphère d'influence de la Russie
a progressivement diminué c'est
justement ça que le combattre
aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine vous restez
avec nous parce qu'on va parler de
l'Europe dans un instant donc sans
surprise la Russie a mis son veto
Conseil de sécurité à une résolution
contre l'invasion russe en Ukraine et
pour le retrait des trop Prusses le
Conseil de l'Europe a suspendu hier la
Russie le président
ukrainien appelle l'Union européenne à
déconnecter la Russie du réseau bancaire
international suisse Swift le système de
transaction financière internationale
Edwige wamanissa
une réunion animée du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU sans surprise le
projet de résolution présenté par les
États-Unis condamnant l'attaque russe
contre l'Ukraine a fait l'objet d'un
véto de la part de la Russie la Russie
ne peut pas mettre son véto à cette
résolution ne peut pas mettre son véto à
nos voix elle ne peut pas mettre son
véto à la vérité
elle ne peut pas mettre son véto à nos
principes
elle ne peut pas mettre son veto au
peuple ukrainien sur les 15 membres du
Conseil 11 pays ont voté en faveur du
texte mais trois se sont abstenus la
Chine l'Inde et les Émirats arabes unis
Pékin affirme être contre la prise de
sanctions qui pleuvent sur la Russie de
son côté le secrétaire général de l'ONU
a appelé à nouveau à cesser les combats
et trouver une solution pacifique
est né de la guerre pour mettre fin à la
guerre
aujourd'hui cet objectif n'a pas été
atteint
mais nous n'abandonnons jamais nous
devons donner une nouvelle chance à la
paix les soldats doivent retourner dans
leur caserne les dirigeants doivent
prendre le chemin du dialogue et de la
paix
en début de semaine
alloché de Kiev
irski à laisser entendre que son pays
pourrait renoncer à son objectif
d'adhésion à l'OTAN un projet que la
Russie considère comme une menace
existentielle pour sa sécurité
et on retrouve donc Joséphine Staron la
leçon de cette crise est-ce que c'est
pas la nécessité d'un traité européen
entre les États européens de défense
mutuelle précisant les stratégies et les
moyens indépendamment du parapluie
américain oui ça fait de nombreuses
années qu'on parle de cette fameuse
Europe de la défense qui peine avoir le
jour aujourd'hui et que c'était
finalement un tabou on avait certains
pays européens qui étaient
satisfait de l'OTAN en pensant que ça
c'est une protection suffisante pour
l'Europe d'autres pays qui comme la
France demandent depuis de nombreuses
années à ce que l'Europe se dot de
capacité de défense autonome en plus de
l'OTAN donc on était dans une situation
un peu bloquée aujourd'hui avec
l'épreuve que nous fait vivre la Russie
il y a de très fortes chances que le
tabou soit enfin levé autour de l'Europe
de la défense et que les États européens
les 27 souhaitent unanimes et trouvent
enfin la manière d'assurer la sécurité
collective du continent bien évidemment
en comptant sur l'OTAN mais pas
uniquement il faut bien voir que depuis
quelques années les États-Unis ont
montré une volonté peut-être d'investir
moins dans l'OTAN au niveau européen de
se retirer un peu des affaires
européennes pour investir d'autres zones
géographiques notamment l’endopacifique
et donc les Européens sont aujourd'hui
face à un véritable défi qui essuie
d'assurer leur propre défense collective
mais ça va nécessiter de lourds
investissements en matière de défense et
c'est là où les négociations entre les
États européens vont être intéressantes
et vivre mais je pense que là on est un
tournant et que les Européens ont tous
conscience quand un nouveau conflit en
tout cas ne pourra pas
ou pourra sonner peut-être la fin de
l'Union européenne si nous ne sommes pas
capables de répondre
efficacement aux menaces qu'on fait
peser sur notre continent merci beaucoup
Joséphine Staron pour votre décryptage
et merci d'avoir été avec nous